Il giorno che ti ho visto l'ho subito capito
tutto quello che ho provato per te questo
Sarò in giro per le estati e il parto non mi conosce
Cuba oggi il gatto ma ci provo
se la parte ovunque e uno di
la mia roba qui quando mi sono perso
sostanze preziose perché io cosa
sapevamo l'aria perché avremmo
Ovviamente non puoi più
e ti amo ora il desiderio mi divora
e non posso perderti
Oggi a Lanzarote
e voglio dirti che non in inverno
Sono passati parecchi anni, si nascondono da noi
che vogliono lasciare i confini
sole spese
[Musica]
e in esso
e il sogno dell'entità e dopo la mancanza di
lei mostra il miglior poster del
erba è ci sono un sacco di bugie su questo
visto che faccio fatica a perderci
oggi e questo caso di maltempo e l'ho visto
pensavamo fosse dove siamo
rima Mr. Elio corre con il
le mani nei tuoi ritmi notturni si commuove
e ti amo
e questo che mi divora e io non posso tu
perdere
non vuoi mai fare niente con due mani
quando viene trattato
[Musica]
in piedi
No
e più vite per favore
per cambiare le sette persone che mi è stato detto
quello a cui non importa con quello o in orbita
La punta latina non è poi apparsa
galleggiante
sono libero
non so non so come
era ieri
E lo ha
[Musica]